on change d'univers on change totalement
d'univers wilfried est ce que vous
faites de la zumba hors antenne
régulièrement chaque soir ces entretiens
j'ai confiance avant les congés
confiance justement la zumba c'est le
sport à la mode complètement qui fait
fureur depuis depuis quelques mois et
pour en parler sur ce plateau une
professeure de zumba on peut pas faire
autrement valérie bleus tendon soir
l'ancien et dominique chanseau vous êtes
la présidente de l'association gym
volontaire de plaisir ou ou valérie
fedon seco tout à fait bonsoir à vous
alors la zumba
qu'est ce que c'est comment ça c'est que
ça marche autant expliquez-nous
ben parce que parce qu'on aime bien
dansé on a envie de se faire plaisir
ces sons des musiques différentes on
entre 8 et 10 musiques différentes donc
ces jeunes se disent type différent oui
le merengues et la salle sein du
reggaeton et plein d'autres styles aussi
donc ça c'est très riche et les gens
viennent bien alors rassurez vous c'est
une danse où c'est un sport parce que
vous parlez de musique l'a donc
peut-être penser que c'est un cours de
danse classique on ne fait pas du glacis
kazuma non c'est pas classique c'est du
sport quand même parce qu'on travaille
le cardio respiratoire la coordination
c'est à dire on bouge à droite à gauche
alors on voit quelques uns de vos cours
café voilà donc c'est bon c'est basé sur
le mouvement et sans sur la musique
oui ben oui par contre il est présenté
et s'est expliqué nous c'est là que
beaucoup de femmes
c'est vrai parce que dans l'association
il ya une majorité de femmes quand même
ça touche aussi un peu les hommes mais
bon je crois peut-être ils ont un peu
peur de donner c'est possible ils sont
les bienvenus quand même une autre
association effectivement constitué
d'adhérents 2 féminine est alors depuis
que vous donnez des cours à plaisir les
adhérentes
je pense aberrante où plus qu'adhérent
viennent en nombre
c'est en pleine explosion assis en
pleine explosion alors je sais pas mais
on a lancé quatre séances zumba et sont
toutes pleines très très rapidement on a
refusé du monde
parce qu'il ya un engouement
effectivement c'est festif c'est facile
d'accès et on peut faire du sport tout
en s'amusant et en prenant beaucoup de
plaisir
en moyenne ce c'est il ya combien de
personnes parcourent c'est une trentaine
oui nous on a préféré limiter pour
garder un peu de la qualité parce que le
but c'est pas de remplir des salles et
de ne pas s'amuser c'est vraiment de
privilégier la qualité des cours alors
est ce qu'il y à des compétitions comme
et championnat de france de danse
sportive etc ou pas du tout bonne
question je pense participer ou non nous
ne faisons pas de compétition non non
non mais maintenant on est dans l'espoir
santé noualhat du score mais sans
compétition et comme ça reste du sport
c'est très encadré aussi bien tout le
monde peut enseigner la zumba
par exemple quel est votre parcours
alors ben moi au départ je suis prof de
gymnastique volontaire ensuite j'ai
évolué sur la marche nordique du pilates
et et là j'ai découvert en fait la zumba
donc je me suis formé tout à fait non
peux pas mentionner comme ça ça
s'apprend pas que nous sommes et par
william diplôme bien sûr avec des
niveaux et puis des spécificités aussi
on peut aussi amener la zumba gold
on appelle ça c'est pour les seniors et
les débutants actif aussi pour les
enfants de 4 7 ans et de 8 12 ans et
aussi du tomeing c'est la zumba pour
renforcement musculaire loyer c'est
quand même assez large mais en ce moment
c'est plus la zumba fitness à fkih à
fond quoi donc ce mode saas qu'il ya eu
la tecktonik par exemple c'est vrai
c'est un sport aussi
je pense que c'est une mode mais qui va
qui va quand même duré parce que les
gens ont envie d'évoluer ont envie de
s'amuser tout en faisant du sport en
fête et le but c'est ça c'est bouger son
corps en s'amusant
1 dominique mais on est vraiment plus
dans le sport que dans la danse ça il
faut bien reconnaître qu'il faut voir se
sentir bien se lâcher prise et c'est pas
toujours évident pour des sportifs qui
ont l'habitude de faire des derniers
mouvements répétés
sans vraiment prendre du plaisir et
s'amuser et là on est vraiment dans un
objectif totalement différents mais qui
reste sportif
merci à toutes les deux d'être venu
j'aurais bien aimé une démonstration
avaient quant à eux pris par le temps
malheureusement merci viendra t viendra
tester des fous ici avec plaisir et on
montrera bien évidemment les images on
poursuit cette chronique sport on va
parler des principaux événements qui se
sont déroulés ce week end